I always wonder because I've been seeing
the community notes recently and I
always wonder if it's Community notes
who like like what process does the
community notes go through to verify and
or not verify I think it's like
Wikipedia where there's just like a team
of like unpaid people basically
communicating about it and like a large
percentage of people doing the community
notes have to agree in order to add the
community note although I'm sure that
that could be gamed to some extent cuz
sometimes you see the community note pop
up and then it goes away do you uh did
you see the obviously you saw the clip
of Elon saying go [__] yourself to Bob
Iger yeah is it Bob Iger to all the
advertisers but he's like hi Bob in the
crowd or whatever did you watch that
full interview I did it was pretty good
I liked a lot of it I think he's kind of
in over his head with telling all the
advertisers to [__] off because he's
supposedly this like free speech guy and
I can't think of a better example of
free speech than corporations deciding
not to advertise with a guy who's
basically created a platform where
there's a lot of unsavory things going
on much of which he's co-signing so I
don't really think that he has any kind
of argument against those advertisers
the idea that he's going to sue these
advertisers for not wanting to adverti
on his platform is AB it is kind of
anti-free speech yeah because they have
the ability to choose where they want to
advertise and I like Twitter being what
it is where there's a lot of free speech
and it's like the only platform where if
there's a fight or if there's something
sexual I know I can put it on Twitter
can't put it on Instagram or YouTube I'm
going to lose my account can't put it on
Snapchat can't put it on pretty much
anywhere fly on Twitter yeah and I
appreciate that but I also think that
you had to put an episode on Twitter
once right because you guys took that
week off because of a strike right yeah
we got a strike for like the dumbest
[__] ever I forget what it was it was
something about I remember the whole
episode was on Twitter though yeah we
had to put it on Twitter it was [__]
depressing as [__] cuz nobody wants to
listen to a two-hour podcast on Twitter
but we just wanted to be able to put our
weeks episode out either way so we I
think if they somehow fix like the I
guess the uh just the platform for video
watching the more and more YouTube
starts like clamping down and like
[__] with creators I could see
Twitter eventually becoming like I mean
but it's going to require advertisers
and they and they have to and they have
to change like it's like you you just
press play on it like it doesn't go
vertical or you doesn't go horizontal
it's just it's just a hard platform to
watch and it doesn't appear that a lot
of people really want to be in the
business of Hosting all this video
content because you look at twitch I
mean twitch could easily a VA style
platform as well like you live stream
and then you can upload your video after
but you can't really upload videos on
Twitch [__] over on there folks uh I
think it's 5050 yeah they take a stupid
ad rate but you're talking about Amazon
the richest [__] company in the world
and they don't want the headache of
having twitch turn into YouTube so that
kind of makes me feel like elon's biting
off a bit more than he can shoot because
it doesn't like you know people aren't
making really significant amounts of
money on Twitter which I guess could
change Twitter ad the ad the ad uh you
probably know more than me cuz face
Facebook's still pretty solid you still
guys you guys got the Facebook booming
right Facebook is pretty nice yeah